[Music]
if we're coding AI and and we understand
that there's moral consequences does
that mean the programmer has to
understand it right it isn't only the
programmer although we do really think
that we need to train programmers to be
watching out for these kinds of
situations knowing how to blow whistle
blow knowing when to whistle blow
they're you know there is a problem with
people being over reactive and that
costs companies I understand that but we
also have sort of a nuremberg situation
that we need everybody to be responsible
but ultimately it isn't just about the
programmers right that programmers work
within the context of a company and the
companies work in the context of
regulation and so it is about law it's
about society one of the things one of
the papers I had come out in 2017 with
Professor Alan Winfield was the thing
about how if legislators can't be
expected to keep up with the pace of
technological change what they could
keep up with is which professional
societies do they trust and then you
could have basically and and they
already do this in various disciplines
it's just new for AI you say you have to
achieve the moral standards of at least
one professional organization so when
they say when they give like their rules
about what's what's okay and that sort
of allows you to kind of a loose
coupling because it's wrong for
professional organizations to you know
to enforce a lot to go after people to
sue them whatever that's not what
professional organizations are for but
it's also sensible the profession it is
what professional organizations are for
is to keep up with their own field and
to set things like codes of conduct and
so that's so that's why you want to
bring those two things together the the
executive government and the
professional organizations and you can
kind of have the legislature joining
those two together this is what I'm
working hard to keep in the regulations
that it's always people and
organizations that are accountable and
so then they will be motivated to make
sure that they can demonstrate they
follow due process so both the people
who are operating the AI and the people
who develop the AI because it's going to
like a car
whether it's a car accident normally you
know the driver is at fault sometimes
the person that hit is at fault because
they did something completely
unpredictable
right but sometimes the manufacturer you
know did something wrong with the brakes
and and that's a real problem
so we need to be able to show that the
manufacturer followed good practice and
it really is the fault of the driver or
sometimes that really there isn't a
there isn't a fact of the matter like it
was just a unforeseeable thing in the
past but of course now it's happened so
in the future we'll be more careful that
just happened recently in Europe there
was a case where somebody was on it
wasn't like a total driverless car but I
guess let's cruise control or something
it had some extra AI and unfortunately
somebody had a stroke now if you what
happens a lot and what am I
automobile manufacturers have to look
for is falling asleep at the wheel but
this guy had a stroke which is different
from flying asleep so he was still kind
of holding on semi in control but
couldn't see anything hit a family and
killed two of the three of the family
and so the survivor was the father and
and and he said he didn't he wasn't
happy only to get you know money from
insurance or whatever the liability or
whatever he wanted to know that whoever
who had caused this accident was being
held accountable so there was a big
lawsuit and and that company was
absolutely it was a car manufacturing
company they're able to show they
followed due process they've been
incredibly careful this was just like a
really unlikely thing to have happened
to have that kind of stroke that she'd
be holding on to the steering wheel and
all these other things and so it was
decided that there was nobody actually
at fault but it could have been
different
if Facebook is really moving fast and
breaking things then they're going to
have a lot of trouble proving that they
were doing due diligence when Cambridge
analytic I got the data that it got and
so so they are very likely to be held to
account for anything that's found to
been a negative consequence of that
behavior and it's something that
computer scientists should want that
that tech completion wants they should
want to be able to show that they've
done the right thing
so there's so everybody who's ever made
any code at all knows there's like two
different pressures one is you want to
have clean beautiful code that you can
understand it's well documented and
everything and and you know that's good
because then if you ever need to change
it or extend it or you want to write
some more software right that's great
you can reuse it other people can reuse
it maybe you'll get famous for your
great code right the other thing is that
you want to put stuff out as soon as you
can because you can sell it faster you
you don't have time whatever you want to
go do something else and so that's why
you make or maybe you don't even
understand you that what's you're really
doing and you've just barely got it to
work or whatever so those two pressures
are always working on each other right
and it's really really important for all
of our benefit for society's benefit
that we put weight on that side of that
nice clean code so that we can tell
questions like I just I like the one I
just mentioned the questions like who's
at fault if data goes the wrong place
right so right now that's not the way
it's been going it has been completely
you know sort of Wild West so nobody can
tell where the data is going right but
with a few lawsuits with a few big
failures I think everyone's going to be
motivated to say no I want I want to
show that the AI did the right thing and
it was the owners fault or that we we
followed due diligence and that was an
unforeseeable consequence you know
they're gonna want to prove that stuff
and like I said that's going to benefit
not just the companies and not just the
the owners or operators but all of us
because it's we want liability to be on
the people who are making the decisions
right and so that's the right way around
so that's that's what we want to
maintain human accountability even
though the autonomous system is
sometimes taking decisions the thing
that drives me crazy astir organizations
do wrong about AI right now is when they
go in and try to fight regulation by
saying oh you'll lose the magic juice
you know like deep learning is the only
reason we've got AI and if you regulate
us then you can't use it because nobody
knows what the weights are doing in deep
learning okay
this is completely false all right first
of all when you audit a company
you don't go and try to figure out how
the synapses are connected in their
accountant so you just look at the
accounts so in the worst case we can do
the same thing with AI that we could be
doing with with humans now again this
goes back to what I was saying earlier
about due diligence if you have
accountants and the accounts are on you
could try to put the account and
understand and say why are the counts
run and then you try to establish
whether they were doing the right thing
at the right time or whatever the you
can't do that with AI systems but if you
want to prove if you want to be able to
prove that there are honest mistakes you
can look at like how is the system
trained you know how was it being run
there's ways that you can audit whether
the system was built appropriately so I
think we should be out looking for those
because then also allows us to improve
our systems so the most important thing
is just not believing the whole magic
line and one of the companies I've heard
give the magic line in a regulatory
setting you know in front of government
representatives was Microsoft and that
was at early 2017 and now they've
completely reversed that they've sat
down they've thought about it and now
they've said accountability and
transparency is absolutely core to what
we should be doing with AI and I think
Microsoft are making really strong
efforts to be the adults in the room
right now
so which is interesting like I said just
literally within one year that there was
that that change so I think everybody
should be thinking that AI is not this
big exception don't look for a way to
get out of responsibility
[Music]
you